let's say you're 12 years old you try to
like push the envelope as much as you
can be like okay can I hint at like buy
content here the thing about trans
Angels which is a site they sell that to
straight men can I can I like talk more
about like what if we brought a trans
Talent onto the site horn um in all of
its forms are so normalized to them and
they're so callous to something as
serious as a child being able to view
pornography this is a breaking news
story I'm really pleased that we were
able to uh get this story and we did not
do the investigation this investigation
was undertaken by a a wonderful uh News
Group this would be sound investigations
I am joined here by one of the
journalists ardan young ardan thank you
for coming on the show thank you so much
for having me Michael so ardan before we
get into how you conducted this
investigation what it all means I want
to just show people some clips of of
what you've uncovered because some of us
have suspected that PornHub and its
parent company formerly called Mind geek
now it's called Alo they have to keep
changing the name because they're an
evil company and they they don't want to
have to uh face the music some of us
have suspected that they've been up to
these kinds of activities for a while
here it is in their own words let's say
you're 12 years old you're still
figuring out your sexuality maybe even
your
gender wouldn't it be help to
see not a celebration but just like
maybe a normalization of something that
you think is what you want you know
probably helps a lot let's say I was 12
and I saw like trans angels I saw all
these different sites it would help me
figure out what I do like and what I
don't like they need
to try to push stuff that's more less
less accepted like putting a putting a a
trans male or trans female in a scene
you wouldn't get that on a normal
mainstream site so test it out see if
you get a bigger audience with it see if
you can convert somebody right like
maybe somebody who's never looked for
anything like that might find it
interesting click on it same thing for
buy stuff same thing for gay that's
another senior script writer at mindgeek
now called Alo but we all know it as
PornHub that's just the biggest
pornographers on the planet two major
discoveries here one they know that kids
are looking at their content they're
totally fine with it it obviously helps
their business model we all knew that
it's crazy to hear it in their own words
we all knew that the second Discovery to
me is the most shocking senior script
writer here at the biggest porn company
on Earth saying yeah we're trying to
convert straight guys into looking at
gay porn or trans por we're always
trying to push the boundaries we're not
even just serving the market that
already exists for porn we're trying to
create new markets by by creating new
Desires in people that they do not
previously have that are certainly out
of the mainstream that are considered
more deviant and and we're going to slip
that content into the porn to ex to
expand the pallet I suppose of the
customer I can't believe they're
admitting this I know I mean I I was
hitting across from him that was
probably one of the last things I was
expecting him to say um um I my
instincts were to just ask him about the
the kinds of things they were marketing
to people because I knew he does
primarily work on gay and trans
pornography sites that's mainly what he
writes and um he was very very open he
was very matter of fact and and in fact
he like you saw he even viewed kids
viewing porn as a positive thing so you
you're conducting this interview
this guy obviously has no idea what's
going on but you'd think if if you were
working for so degenerate a company a
and you were engaged in such even today
frowned upon kinds of behaviors you
might play it a little closer to the
vest right he didn't though did it take
much prodding or was he just open about
this he was extremely open about this
and this we're talking about Dylan in
particular the senior script writer for
Alo um he was extremely open extremely
obliging did not think my questions were
strange or out of place at all um and it
goes to show you kind of the mindset
these employees of this company are in
porn um in all of its forms are so
normalized to them and they're so
callous to something as serious as a
child being able to view
pornography but of course we all know
and in fact in one of your interviews
you you mentioned that the the median
age of exposure to pornography now for
kids is something like 11 frankly I'm
surprised it's that high I I I would
even suspect it might be lower maybe
today it is lower we all know that kids
are accessing porn and that's how the
porn
companies cultivate and groom their
their future crop of customers because
kids brands are very very malleable if
they get addicted to this stuff when
they're 10 or 11 years old they're going
to stick with it for a very long time
most
likely again it's horrifying they should
be prosecuted for it it's just evil it's
great to hear them admit it the thing
that is so shocking to me I guess is
that we have been told for my entire
life by the left by the the pro
pornography people by the sexual
revolutionaries that sexual desire is
innate and immutable it's an
orientation nobody
becomes gay bisexual trans it's not you
you're just you're born that way and how
dare you suggest how I we'll probably be
kicked off of social media for even for
even repeating what this top porn
employee is who writes the stuff who
know he knows what he's talking about
what he is admitting on camera we'll
probably be be kicked off even for
repeating it but but what he is saying
is yeah n that's all bunk actually yeah
you can convert people that's how our
business model works you got to slip in
this weirder stuff so you take a guy
who's been straight his whole life who's
never entertained any other kind of
thought
and then you try to get him well
actually you went even in Greater depth
with him let's play that clip the thing
is it's like when you write for like
Sean Cody which is like primarily gay
targeted when you write for Trans Angels
which trans uh female presenting
targeted you also try to see how much
you can take of that and bring it to
mainstream vanilla content right cuz
like brazers and Reality Kings is
predominantly for straight men but
you try to like push the envelope as
much as you can be like okay can I hint
at like buy content here can I can I
like talk more about like what if we
brought a trans Talent onto the site and
you kind of like take those risks to try
and broaden it a little bit more even
though you know that you have a site
dedicated to that right like you're
always trying to push a little further
cuz the thing is the thing about trans
Angels which is a site um it's female
presenting trans women it's and like
they sell that to straight men like
that's the demographic there it is
there's they are they're trying to trans
the straight guys that that's not my
words don't hey hey social media
companies don't take me off for saying
that that's with the senior writer at
mindgeek the guy who writes all of this
porn he is saying we are trying to take
straight guys our Target demo is
converting straight guys into trans guys
yeah and you know I think I think he
meant convert in the marketing sense
which doesn't really make it any better
um well it's the same sense and yes I
there's a whole conversation be had
about the business model and capitalism
but it when we're talking about a
product that involves at a very deep
level your own desires and your own
identity then when you convert people to
the product you're converting them in
their desire and their identity exactly
and I think they're completely motivated
by profits they just want to make
more a wider variety of content more
palatable and um more profitable to the
single viewer um and you know going back
to Children accessing pornography we're
seeing more and more ID laws past in the
US so now in many states it's required
to verify your age before entering a
pornographic site um Alo and the parent
company of PornHub is actively suing
some of these US states trying to stop
this from happening because they openly
admit that requiring their ID before
accessing porn actually drives down
their traffic by 80% so for them
protecting children is not a concern
maximizing profits is 100% their concern
and they don't seem to care who they
harm in the process of course not I
thought it told the whole story when
Utah first pass I think it was Utah
passed that that uh ID law and instantly
born said okay we're not doing business
in the state of Utah anymore you said
well there you go there there you have
it Arden tell me a little bit about the
investigation itself whatever you can
without compromising your methods of
course uh well we were inspired to
investigate PornHub in the first place
because of a 2020 New York Times article
called the children of PornHub it really
detailed uh struggles of often underage
people to get their abuse videos taken
off of PornHub which were being
advertised and
monetized um so PornHub was benefiting
monetarily from these videos as well as
the abusers uploading the videos and
through months and months of requests
and and begging PornHub to take these
videos down uh the videos were not taken
down only after legal action was taken
this article came out did PornHub start
really getting scared and taking these
things seriously but our premise for the
whole investigation was maybe their
concern was just lip service and and
maybe these things are really still
going on so that's what we sought out to
prove and we did we have um multiple
previous Undercover videos we've
published that detail just the lack of
agent consent verification for
pornographic uploads and pornographic
ads going on the site um advertising por
to appeal to pedophiles and young teens
uh we just have a plethora of undercover
footage that we've been putting out you
would think well this is a ridiculous
premise I guess but if you were an
executive at PornHub and you had any
modom of a moral conscience and you
found
out that you've got child pornography on
the site that there are ads being
targeted to pedophiles and that the
moment that you say no more kids get to
look at PornHub your users drop by
80% that would cause you to reflect and
say wow this is really bad but they
don't instead they say if you make us in
any way try to keep kids off the site
we're going to boycott your whole state
exactly and in those States now the only
way to access PornHub is through a VPN
which they also own VPN Hub um and up
until not too long ago it was actually
rated for ages 4 and up in the App
Store yeah so VPN Hub is that is that's
obviously not just a porn thing if it's
a if it's ages 4 plus it's just a VPN
that anyone can use to mask their right
it's just a VPN owned by PornHub Wow
have they explained why they keep
changing the name I you know they they
went through new ownership at the
beginning of 2023 it was actually bought
uh a firm called eth ethical Capital
Partners um and so they went through
this entire Rebrand and renamed it Alo
because of you know all the bad press
they had gotten under mind geek so I I
think they're they're really they they
tout themselves as the the leader in
compliance the leader in ethics of the
adult industry but if they truly are the
leader in ethics of the adult industry
we have a huge problem people have
written into to me and whenever I've
cover I interviewed a former porn
performer and and had a long interview
with him and people would write in about
their terrible relationship to porn
young men write into my show all the
time they say I'm addicted to porn I've
been looking at it since I was 10 years
old and I have read accounts of men who
say I was just a strike guy I was just a
normal strike guy I was married I was
and then I fell into this kind of weird
transp porn and now I think I'm a chick
or or you'd hear I interviewed a trans
Widow a woman who whose husband left her
to go pretend to be a woman and I I I
spoke to another expert on this subject
and she said that pornography use even
like mainstream stuff the biggest porn
company in the world PornHub porn use is
an extraordinary predictor of people
falling into this transgender identity
this is something again I don't think
I'm allowed to say it on social media
this part will probably just have to be
behind the daily wire pay wall or on X
but I I don't ever want to hear a social
media company say that that's
disinformation they've got to take me
off off the air for saying that again
you're hearing it straight from the
horse's mouth absolutely and you know
we've gotten comment from Alo before on
our past releases where different
employees admit to different things and
in one of them they actually alleg that
the employee is too high ranking to know
what he's talking about in the video
he's he's too powerful how could he
possibly know what his underlings are
doing you've got to be kidding me yeah
yeah so their responses to us have just
gotten increasingly
ridiculous um you know they've actually
bragged about the fact that they report
fewer incidences of child exploitation
to the National Center um child
exploitation or like missing and
exploited children um which is a
requirement for us-based companies so
they're bragging that they've reported
fewer incidences to the
ncmec than other major Tech platforms
but the logic says actually you should
be reporting as much as you can because
we know these things are happening on a
platform literally dedicated to
pornography where random users are
uploading pornographic videos and by the
way if a user's face is not in a video
if it's filmed from the neck down say
which is very very common it is
impossible for these content moderators
to verify that a face an on an ID
matches a body and we have one of the
employees saying it that he was very
concerned about that loophole as he
calls it at one point but when he
brought it up to leadership he was told
to f off and shut up so there is this
loophole gate being wide open for
children to be uploaded for you know
young teens to be uploaded or you know
date rapes different rapes um to be
uploaded and and no one would know
there's so much more to say about this I
I know you're very busy thank you for
giving me so much of your your time uh
the takeaways here for me if you are a
private individual call your Congressman
if you use the political order this is
this is as clear-cut a case for for
proper political action as I've ever
seen stop looking at porn if for no
other reason then the senior writers
here are saying they want to make you
gay and trans okay they want to screw up
your head and twist your desires and and
wrench your very identity if for no
other reason at least out of
self-preservation don't do that ardan
incredible incredible work thank you so
much for coming on can't wait to hear
more and I can't wait to hear the
excuses from these
psychos thank you so much Michael it's a
pleasure